so as we get into our video about Damian
Wayne we're going to be doing here is
we're going to be focusing on Damian
Wayne in the new 52 and the reason why
is because if you've seen our video
about Jason Todd or Dick Grayson or Tim
Drake we've focused on them pre new 52
because in some former fashion their
earliest introductions into DC Comics
pave the way for incredible changes and
these sort of character based
revolutions within the comic book
industry as a whole but Damian Wayne
doesn't do that instead Damian Wayne's
profound impact on comic books comes in
the form of his impact on Batman and not
just Bruce Wayne himself but in terms of
Alfred and how it is that Bruce Wayne
and Alfred
view the world around them
so in the new 52 DC pretty much keeps
the pre new 52 origins of Damian Wayne
the same what we know is that Damian
Wayne is the child of both Bruce Wayne
and Talia al Ghul now one of the big
controversies that took place with
Damian Wayne's initial introduction into
DC Comics was the idea that Bruce Wayne
had effectively been drugged and that
when he was drugged he was basically
seduced by Talia al Ghul then the two of
them of course had intercourse and the
result was that Damian Wayne came into
the world but for the most part this is
just considered to be the Canon part of
Damian Wayne's existence this is simply
just how it was he became part of the DC
landscape now following the introduction
of Damian Wayne following him coming
into the world for the most part he was
raised almost single-handedly Battaglia
al Ghul and the goal here for Talia al
Ghul was to make Damian Wayne this
extremely formidable opponent somebody
who could basically be on par with
Batman but more so than that her drive
was to effectively disrupt the endeavors
of that man within the realm of Gotham
City and so what happens is that over
the course of Damian Wayne's young life
leading into his teenage years he's
taken by Talia al Ghul and trained to be
an assassin and this is done in some of
the most harshest of environments in
ways that would test even the most
durable I guess maybe the most
battle-hardened soldier and so as things
progressed with Damian Wayne we
ultimately find that any real siblings
of social structure any real siblings of
what it means for him to effectively
begin to I guess identify with other
people or to develop empathy begins to
go away and so effectively Damian Wayne
is simply just raised to be a sociopath
an extremely violent murderous and
talented sociopath but a sociopath
nonetheless now eventually the time
comes when Damian Wayne is handed over
to Batman and so what we're going to do
here is we're actually going to jump to
the stories of Batman and Robin from the
new 52 because this is where I really
really think Damian Wayne steps away
from just being this kind of sadistic
character to becoming more in depth and
we actually get this really good
characterization about him that we
really don't see anywhere else and what
I mean by that is Damian Wayne's
inability to communicate with other
people is inability to identify to
basically reach other people on a
personal level becomes more prevalent
here and then
anywhere else inocent Ruth is
established to us in the dialogue of
Damian Wayne when he and Bruce Wayne are
conversing with one another we see Bruce
Wayne more human than we ever saw him
before when he's standing beside Damian
Wayne some really good examples are when
Bruce Wayne is talking about the death
of his parents when he's actually taking
Damian Wayne to the to the location
where his parents were killed in Crime
Alley and Damian Wayne really says this
is a waste of time there's really no
point in doing this there's other things
that could be doing instead now some
people would probably chalk this up to
simply saying he never knew the Wayne's
as Grandparents but more so than that
in terms of it simply just being family
that he never knew most people would
really sort of longed to meet those
individuals they would really want to
learn more about them to understand
where they missed out on this lineage of
their I guess of their heritage in terms
of their family relations but for Damian
Wayne it's not this way for Damian Wayne
it's simply just a circumstance whereby
there were people he never knew and
because he never knew them they are
irrelevant to him and Batman picks up on
this in fact that man tells him on
multiple occasions to show some respect
to show the kind of respect that's
necessary here and this is basically
Batman realizing that with Damian Wayne
being his son and Damian Wayne having
been raised by Talia al Ghul the way
that he was to be basically a sociopath
here
it's his goal to effectively fix this
and in fact when he's conversing with
Alfred he goes as far as to point this
out to say that whatever it was a Talia
al Ghul had done with Damian Wayne
effectively broke him and that Batman's
goal is to basically fix Damian Wayne -
which of course Alfred replies and
saying that Batman's role here is to be
a father not to be a mechanic and so the
argument that Batman is making here is
that the idea is hoping that nurture
that his role as a father his ability to
try to reach to Damian Wayne can win out
over the nature the violent I guess a
patterns of violent mindsets that Talia
al Ghul had instilled and still in him
as a child and so over the course of
Damian Wayne's tenure as Robin which of
course he's basically immediately
inducted into this role by virtue of
simply just being the son of Batman he
basically takes his very cold-hearted
approach when it comes to criminals as
far as Damian weight is concerned it's
no issue to kill criminals it's no issue
to pummel criminals because again with
the training that he had received on
behalf of
Talia al Ghul it's more important to
kill your adversary so they can never
come back
then they give them a chance to fix
themselves and this highlights the
inherent difference between Damian Wayne
and Batman Batman believes that
regardless of how sadistic criminals are
there has to be some way to try to
rehabilitate them even if it means
spending countless years rounding them
up and taking them back to Arkham Asylum
again there has to be a way to fix them
and if there isn't then they should
simply just be held away from regular
society but Batman does not believe
under normal circumstances in killing
violent criminals in Gotham City Damian
Wayne would rather just see them killed
off and gone and so again we see Batman
chastising Damian Wayne over this kind
of thing we see Batman chastising Damian
Wayne over his willingness to kill other
people over the fact that as far as he's
concerned the lives of criminals don't
really matter here in addition we
actually get some really really cool
dialogue between Damian Wayne and Alfred
and this is I think one of the most
important aspects of the stories I guess
of Damian Wayne's existence in DC Comics
there comes a point over the course of
the Batman and Robin series where we see
Alfred and Damian Wayne sitting down and
playing a game of chess and this is
almost like a scene out of a film of
some sort whereby they're simply just
conversing back and forth then what
Alfred is telling Damian Wayne is that
chess is not simply just a game whereby
you move some pieces around a board and
hopefully you win chess is a reflection
of the lessons of life and that you have
to have your head in multiple places you
have to be thinking in multiple places
you have to be thinking in the future
you have to be thinking in the past you
have to be in your own head focusing on
the moment but you also have to be in
your opponent's head anticipating what's
coming down the road and what he's
basically trying to do here is to
communicate to - Damian Wayne that it's
not enough to just have a very
particular set of skills it's not enough
to basically be an assassin you have to
be someone who can identify with other
people who can reach out to other people
because the strengths of others would
add to the strength of his own but
Damian Wayne doesn't really want to hear
this Damian Wayne simply just wants to
be a character who goes out fights on
behalf of Batman and then kills
criminals in the process now again
without going too deep into the further
stories in the new 52 because we're some
we're going to be going back and I guess
talking about endgame and talking about
core to the owls and things like that
Damian Wayne will eventually go on to
basically adopt his role at Batman or
I'm sorry of Robin full-bore he'll
basically begin to sort of take this
kind of turn whereby he'll step into
this role entirely well who began to
slowly move away from being this very
violent person and begin to become
someone that they can actually identify
with other people they can actually go
as far as to say that he trusts other
people with that being said I think this
is one more oh I guess one of our more
interesting videos I think it was it was
enjoyable to actually focus on the
character himself as opposed to simply
just say here's a chronology when he
appeared and some stuff happened but let
me know what you guys think but that
being said I will catch you guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly